[Music]
so the last question is
what is the sign of jonah and its
relationship
to jesus's death and resurrection
what is the relationship between the
resurrection and baptism by immersion
okay the sign of jonah matthew 12 verse
40 for as jonah was in three days and
three nights in the whale's belly even
so shall the son of man be three days
and three nights in the heart of the
earth and so jonah spent three years
tonight in the well
christ will stay there three nights in
the heart of the earth in other words he
was buried now that's three days three
nights does not mean three literal days
at night it was just an expression
referring to any part of each day
but part of the first day he was in the
grave part of the second small part of
the third that counts was three or three
nights in the jewish mind and so it is
just christ is using that as a symbol of
the fact that he too would be buried
within something for three days three
nights as jonah was three days three
nights in the whale's belly christ will
be in the belly of the earth or the
heart of the earth now what's the second
part of that question
the second part of the question is
what is the relationship between the
resurrection and baptism by immersion
oh
romans chapter 6 verse from verse 1 what
shall we say then shall we continue and
sin that grace may abound god forbid how
shall we that the dead to sin live any
longer they remember no not that so many
of us as were baptized into christ were
baptized into his death in other words
you must participate in the death of
christ before you participate in the
resurrection of christ because there are
two events the death and the
resurrection
someone coming to christ must die with
christ on the cross you die to your past
life you die so completely that you're
literally dead and are buried you see
you don't bury your living person you
don't bury a half dead person a half
dead person is still alive and many
people come to christ only half dead to
the past life we must die
when the soldiers came to the cross to
check the three prisoners christ and the
two thieves they wanted to break their
legs to hasten their death they found
that christ was already dead in
revelation 1 18 christ says i was dead
we must be dead with christ our past
life that we might rise so when you're
buried in baptism it symbolizes that you
were truly you've given up your past
life now you're being buried and only
the dead should be buried when you come
out of the water it is the newness of
life spoken of in romans 6 4 as he was
buried even so we rise to walk a newness
of life
the same way when the literal
resurrection comes we shall live a new
life in the new world with christ
[Music]
you